y pasamos ahora a nuestro invitado del
día y para ello me acompaña a Chloe la
vernier quien es una de las reporteras
que junto a mamá Eva puré fue la
realizadora de nuestra última emisión de
los observadores Línea Directa club de
bienvenida Gracias por estar en el
estudio de France 24 ahora en este
programa que los invitamos a ver por
cierto a nuestros televidentes hay una
explicación del fenómeno de pandillas
que recrudece las múltiples crisis en el
país más empobrecido de América Latina
Así que lo que quisiera Chloe es que las
dos navegaremos un poco por lo que fue
la experiencia de realizar este
reportaje normalmente para Línea Directa
se viaja al terreno en cuestión pero en
esta ocasión no fue posible para ustedes
porque razón
Sí exactamente es un informe que
realizamos a distancia por dos razones
principalmente primero el punto es que
hay una inseguridad muy fuerte ahora en
el país es decir que las bandas
controlan gran parte de la capital hay
varios donde no es posible registrar sin
tener el permiso de las bandas también
hay el problema de las Balas Perdidas
que causan heridos muertos Además de eso
hay muchos secuestros que en todos los
barrios Así que debido a este problema
de inseguridad era muy complicado viajar
allá para hacer este informe y la otra
razón por la cual trabajamos a
distancias que es un informe que
preparamos para el programa de los
observadores que es el programa de
nuestro canal que siempre es realizado a
distancia a partir de imágenes
aficionadas de los ciudadanos que que
los ciudadanos nos mandan directamente o
que encontramos en las redes sociales
así que por eso es un trabajo que
hicimos desde París y Bogotá de hecho
podríamos decir que es el punto más alto
del periodismo ciudadano los
observadores Cuáles son las dificultades
y cuáles son también las ventajas que
tiene hacer un trabajo como este a
distancia
hay varias ventajas primero logramos
hablar con decenas de personas que
estaban distintos barrios sin ponernos
en riesgo y sobre todo Sin poner en
riesgo estas personas que es lo más
importante especialmente para los
habitantes que están en estos barrios
controlados totalmente por las bandas
además la ventaja de trabajar de
trabajar a distancias que usamos
imágenes aficionadas de los ciudadanos y
también de las bandas la ventaja de eso
es que nos permite tener imágenes
inéditas poco vistas al contrario de las
imágenes de agencias de prensa por
ejemplo en el caso de Haití los
periodistas no pueden ir a todos los
barrios para grabar para hacer
entrevistas porque el enfrentamientos
porque las bandas controlan las entradas
Así que los periodistas ni siquiera
pueden hacer el trabajo de terreno Así
que muchas veces estas imágenes
aficionadas son las únicas que hay para
ilustrar algo que ha pasado o una
situación en los barrios y sin embargo
pues obviamente no siempre es fácil
trabajar a distancia Por ejemplo en
nuestro caso a veces fue complicado
verificar la ubicación de ciertos vídeos
porque muchas veces para geolocalizar
los vídeos usamos una herramienta que se
llama Google street you que permite
visualizar las calles y los edificios de
Pues de ciertos lugares pero es una
herramienta que casi no funciona en
Puerto Príncipe que es la capital de
Haití Así que nos tocó como encontrar
otras técnicas para verificar las
ubicaciones y también hay datos que no
eran como fáciles de verificar como la
cantidad de bandas que hay ahora en
Haití y también el control que tienen O
sea la digamos la magnitud del control
que tienen en el territorio que no era O
sea no era tan fácil verificarlo a
distancia claro y que lo hemos visto
mucho ahora que mencionaba las agencias
internacionales justamente para nosotros
en redacción es difícil a veces tener
acceso a lo que sucede en Haití Porque
casi nadie se anima a entrar y a grabar
lo que sucede en ese país donde a
propósito ustedes nos mencionaron al
inicio del reportaje que son 150 bandas
en el país y que la mayoría de esas
bandas se ubican en Puerto Príncipe Cómo
es que las bandas Se tomaron Haití y que
tienen absolutamente invadida la capital
Sí o sea ahora todas las fuentes con las
cuales hablamos nos dijeron que las
bandas controlan la mayoría de la
capital O sea no te podría decir si
controlarán el 50% del 80% pero gran
parte de la capital y además de eso
controlan días importantes en la capital
pero también
habías afuera de la capital o sea por
ejemplo en la salida sur de la capital
es casi imposible
o sea pasar porque hay muchas bandas y y
pues entonces hay un control total de de
De esta zona debido a a estas bandas
claro y ahí pues una de las grandes
cosas que ustedes destacan es que el
mayor sufrimiento lo padecen los civiles
que al final no tienen nada que ver con
estos enfrentamientos entre las bandas y
el gobierno de
Lejos de esta corrupción política que
permite la existencia de las bandas Cómo
es la situación de los ciudadanos es muy
difícil ahora o sea todos los habitantes
con los cuales con los cuales hablamos
nos dijeron que era muy complicado para
ella porque pues hay enfrentamientos
entre las bandas que causan muertos
muchos muertos y como tú lo dijiste la
mayoría de los de las víctimas son
civiles además de estos enfrentamientos
que causan muertos también hay el
problema de las Balas Perdidas que ya
mencioné un poquito
hablamos en el informe de un barrio que
se llama solino en el en el cual no hay
enfrentamientos directamente entre las
bandas pero a pesar de eso Hay muchas
Balas Perdidas que llegan y están
muertos heridos todo el tiempo hablamos
con un médico de un centro de salud en
este barrio que nos dijo que cada semana
reciben dos o tres personas por pues
heridas por Balas Perdidas y cuando la
situación se vuelve más intensa pueden
ser como 10 personas que llegan heridas
al centro de salud por Balas Perdidas
también hablamos con otro habitante de
otro barrio que así te solía donde
ocurrió una masacre en julio que nos
dijo que sabían que en cualquier momento
pueden morir por bala perdida y de hecho
poco tiempo después de hablar con este
habitante me mandó una foto de una chica
de 17 años muerta porque había recibido
una bala perdida y esta chica era su
amiga y y además de Pues de estas
masacres de estas Balas Perdidas hay
todo el tema de los secuestros que son
numerosos que son que ocurren en todos
los barrios de la ciudad y entonces la
gente no se desplazar de forma libre sin
tener miedo de sin estar secuestrada y
además de esta violencia digamos muy
directa podemos decir que la falta de
acceso a la educación la falta de acceso
a la salud también es una forma de
violencia dado que muchos hospitales y
escuelas han tenido que cerrar porque no
pueden funcionar en este contexto pues
mire aquí lo que usted nos está
mostrando es esta multiplicidad desde
crisis que vive Haití desde hace décadas
y que no ha podido ser solucionada de
ninguna manera ahora paralelamente
ustedes nos hablaba de las Balas
Perdidas y esto también evidencia un
poco esta gran dificultad de la
infraestructura que tienen en Haití con
casas que son de latón que pueden ser
atravesadas fácilmente por una bala y
que muchas veces producen Víctimas de
este fenómeno así que bueno nos estamos
quedando ya sin tiempo Chloe pero el
agradecimiento es para ustedes no
solamente por sentarse con nosotros sino
por arriesgarse a contar una realidad
que a todos nos interesa pero que
difícilmente tenemos acceso a ella y se
nos fuera un tema que sin embargo sí
tratan ustedes en el reportaje y es esa
pasividad de las autoridades para
enfrentar a las bandas criminales Además
de que no tienen suficiente armamento
para enfrentarse en caso de que lo
quisieran hacer y no estuvieran
enfermedades por la corrupción sin más
lo que nos queda ese invitar a todos los
televidentes a que se queden con
nosotros no solamente en directo América
sino que visiten nuestro sitio web24.com
y ahí pueden dar clic en los
observadores y ver este capítulo tan
interesante y tan difícil que sea
grabado sobre Haití gracias a ustedes
Chloe gracias